firefighters in southern Utah battling
an unprecedented wildfire for this time
of year the Brian head fire has burned
at least 13 homes it covers more than 71
square miles that is larger than
Washington DC the fire is one of dozens
of burning across the West the region
continues to suffer from a heat wave
Jamie yuccas is at a command center in
penguia CH Utah Jamie good morning good
morning Charlie fire fighters 1,400 of
them are doing everything in their power
to try to get this fire under control
they're even using bulldozers to try to
draw fire air lines around the worst
part of this blaze but right now the
fire is only nine percent contained
that's because on Monday they face
severe weather conditions like low
humidity high winds and extreme heat
that forced more evacuations to the
north of this fire today the weather
should be a little bit better but many
are worried it just can't contend with
this extreme fire season officials say
they've never seen anything like this a
wind fueled fire covering so much ground
so quickly so early in the fire season
what's the worst-case scenario with this
fire the worst-case scenario is if the
weather conditions continue just as they
are and that's very windy fire
Information Officer David Akers says red
flag warnings are in place for the next
few days
meaning the dangerous fire conditions
will continue it's been a wind-driven
fire from the very beginning winds up to
30 miles an hour gusts even higher than
that and when wind is pushing a fire at
that kind of speed it's very difficult
to get out of from there for the
firefighters more than 1500 people in
the fires path have been forced to
evacuate I just don't want anybody to
get hurt and if the cabin burns we'll
deal with it and rebuild it but you
can't replace a life firefighters in the
West are also battling the heat
temperatures hit the mid-90s in Prescott
Arizona near a fire that's burned 1,500
acres and in Southern California the
mercury hit close to a hundred degrees
when a wild fire broke out west of Palm
Springs it quickly consumed five
thousand acres closing down a highway
and prompting an evacuation warning for
two mountain community
meanwhile firefighters here in Utah
don't expect to contain this fire until
mid July now this is unusual because
it's so early in the season
it is normally this kind of fire in this
area would probably be more like in
August so it's pretty unprecedented for
this time of year to see this kind of
fire activity and behavior this fire
began by someone using a blowtorch to
burn weeds we don't know who that person
is or if they'll face any charges so far
the cost to fight this fire is at seven
million dollars Nora alright Jamie thank
you so much